in this video I'll show you how to
program a new key for your Jeep vehicle
using this simple key kit this
particular simple key works for a
variety of models from Chrysler Dodge
and Jeep but today we will just be going
over the Jeep Vehicles listed on the
back here you can see that's the
commander 2006 to 2009 Compass 07 to17
Grand Cherokee 05 to 07 Liberty 08 to 12
Wrangler 07 to8
if you are looking for a jeep that is
not listed here on the back we should
have another another video for you on
this channel um and there are also
videos for these chrys learn Dodge
vehicles listed that is a separate video
because the process is a little bit
different and if you're looking for a
different um make entirely just go check
out our Channel we should have you
covered there are tons of these simple
keys that match up with almost every
making model out there so let's just get
this started this is a quick and easy
process um it'll save you a ton of money
compared to doing it at the
dealership so inside we have the easy
installer a new key that we will be
programming and the user
guide the first thing you want to do is
check the seal on the easy installer
this is actually a part that will we
will plug into your car in a little bit
if this says void or it is missing or
damaged you'll want to take this whole
thing back to the retailer where you got
it and get yourself a new one because if
this is uh removed it has probably been
used on another car and once you use it
on a vehicle it will be paired with that
vehicle and it will not work with other
vehicles so make sure that that is good
to go you will need to get this physical
key cut before you start the process you
can do that at your local hardware store
and you will need to have your working
key the one that you currently use with
your your vehicle with you to get this
done and one more thing worth mentioning
is that your new key will only have the
functions um that your old key had so as
you can see I have the same key over
here but it doesn't have the trunk
button if this is the the key I
currently use with my vehicle I can
still program this new key but this
button won't work that's just how it
goes you can't add new functions to your
key in this
process now the first step is activating
our new key fob uh go ahead and look on
screen now I will show you a chart with
all of the different um activation codes
just find the key fob the picture of the
key fob that you currently use and look
down that column and make sure that the
um model and year of your vehicle is
there and reference that uh activation
code right there just write it down or
remember it it's just a three-digit code
um and then we can move on to punch that
into your new key
now I'm going to show you another image
here if you use the three button key fob
pictured in the bottom right and your
vehicle's model and year is listed there
at the top you'll want to flip your key
over to the back the original working
key that you have and check the FCC ID
if the FCC ID matches the one on screen
you'll want to forget the code that you
saw on the previous image and use the
code 233 this only applies to those view
that have the three button key fob and
the models and years listed on this
image okay now I'll show you how to get
this done what we want to do is take our
new key and first press lock and panic
simultaneously this light will come on
and stay on which means we can now punch
in our activation code I will show you
231 so I'll um put in the first digit
with the lock button second panic and
Third unlock
press twice for two one two 3 and one so
now I've punched in 2 3 1 I will press
lock and panic once again and this light
should blink back our
code one two pause one 2 3 pause one so
that means you're good to go onto the
next step but if for example you try to
punch in your code and you see this
blinking that just means that it's not
recognizing the code you can keep trying
this process um until it works there's
no um problem if you have to try many
times but once we move on to the next
step which is pairing you will never
want to try to activate your key again
because that will cause it not to work
so let me just show you one more time
this time I'll show you 2 three
three twice on the lock
button three times on
Panic three times on unlock and now
simultaneously lock and panic
one two pause one two 3 pause one two 3
there we go once you have that punched
in you can move on to the next step so
grab your easy installer your new key
your old key the one that works with
your vehicle uh your user guide and go
ahead and hop in your vehicle the first
thing we want to do is locate the OBD
Port you can see on screen an image of
an OBD Port that's what it looks like
it's usually under the dash almost down
at the level of the pedals so go check
under there see if you can find it if
not check your owner's manual uh that
comes with your car and that information
should be in there once you have that
located take everything that I just
mentioned get in the vehicle close all
of the doors make sure the car is off in
park and put your hazard lights
on now we'll set the dial position
position of the easy installer so come
over here and set your dial position to
one if it's on one just leave it there
if not set it to one all of the models
and years for this particular simple key
use one so don't worry about it the only
exception there is those that have a
Jeep Grand Cherokee you'll want to try
the pairing process that I'm about to
show you with the dial position on one
first and if that doesn't work you'll
set it to two and I'll uh talk more on
that in a little bit but once you have
this set to one you can take your
original working key insert it in turn
the vehicle on start the
engine can come over now remove the seal
on your easy
installer just tear that off and insert
it into the OBD Port once this is
plugged in we'll have about 5 minutes to
work before the computer of your vehicle
times out um the the whole process will
just take you a minute but it's just
good to be aware that you'll need to
work at a steady Pace to get this done
if you wait longer than 5 minutes this
will start to beep and you'll just need
to unplug it and start this process
again so once you plug that in it's go
time and you have to follow these next
steps carefully once the easy installer
is plugged into the OBD Port all you'll
want to do is wait up to 8 seconds and
listen for three quick beeps which
sounds like this that means that your
vehicle has recognized that we're
starting the pairing process and you can
move on to the next step if you hear a
different type of beeping sound then
you'll want to skip ahead to the end of
the video where I go over the errors
that you can run into and how to fix
them once you've heard the three beeps
you can now turn off your vehicle remove
the old key insert your new key into the
ignition and turn it to the on or run
position do not start the engine you'll
want to turn turn it to the final
position before starting the
engine now look over here in the easy
installer there's a button right up on
top press that once once you've pressed
it wait up to 8 seconds and listen for
three quick beeps which again sounds
like
this once you've heard that uh you are
pretty much finished all you want to do
is remove the new key take it out no key
in the ignition vehicle off and press
this button one more time
you should hear a chime sound coming
from the easy installer which sounds
like this and if you hear that that
means you're finished and your new key
is paired to your vehicle and you'll
just want to unplug this from the OBD
port and go ahead and test your keys
your new and your old key should both
work they will both be paired with your
vehicle and you can actually continue
this process to pair a total of eight
keys to your vehicle so if you had
another new key um cut and ready to to
go that you wanted to pair with your
vehicle you can use the same easy
installer and just follow the um the
process that I just showed you again for
a total of eight
Keys now I will quickly go over some of
the errors that you can run into all
this information is available in your
user
guide starts over on page 11 so if the
easy installer BL uh beeps eight times
after pushing the button to initiate the
pairing process
that means that Eight Keys have already
been paired to your vehicle and you will
not be able to pair another as I
mentioned um there's a maximum of eight
keys that you can have paired to your
vehicle and so this will not work and
their solution is to contact them at
their customer service number which you
can see right there and also I just want
to point out that over on page 13 you
can find their um their customer service
number it's asking here can I use the
easy installer the same easy installer
on other vehicles no you cannot once you
plug this in um it will be paired to
your vehicle and it will not work on
other
vehicles if the easy installer sounds
two or three beeps at 1 second intervals
three times and then beeps continuously
uh this can mean one of are two
different errors there so the two beeps
means that the device has already been
used on another vehicle just another way
of saying that um it will not work
and if you're hearing three distinct
beeps at 1 second intervals this means
that your working key your old key
that's currently paired to your vehicle
is not present it needs to be close by
in the car with you so that it can
detect the key and uh you can continue
with the process so just go ahead and
grab your key and make sure that it is
close
by here it says simply the new key won't
pair to my car usually the error is that
um it is an incorrect dial position so
all of all of the models and years for
Jeep use the dial position one except
for the J Grand Cherokee which should
work with one but if it doesn't you'll
want to switch this over to two and
start the pairing process from zero so
turn off your vehicle remove all of the
keys close your doors put it in park
hazard lights on and start the pairing
process again with dial position two and
that should get you sorted
out the easy installer was unplugged
during the pairing process what do you
do well it's no problem um you'll just
need to start the pairing process again
uh you can't continue from where you
left off when you unplugged it you'll
need to start a fresh pairing process so
as I mentioned um in the previous
frequently Asked question you'll just un
uh you remove all of the keys from your
vehicle make sure it's off in park doors
closed and start again and you shouldn't
have any problems you can just keep
trying that process again and again
until you get it
right and it says if the vehicle won't
start with the new or the old key after
attempting to pair that is some kind of
an error that you've run into and their
solution is just to give them a call
over at that number which again is on
page 13 in this book If you prefer
to um just reference their own chart all
of that information that I gave you on
um the activation codes and the dial
position is listed right in here for
Jeep that's page six six and seven so
that's the whole process as I mentioned
if you wanted you could just keep going
and pairing uh more um keys to your
vehicle and this will continue to work
with your vehicle but it will not work
with others so I hope this video was
easy enough to follow I hope it helped
you out and I hope you saved a ton of
money doing this process at home
compared to doing it at the dealership
so thank you so much for watching and
have a great day